let's all right let's answer some of
your questions nelly
with a y
did nagy ruin the bears season when he
made the switch to nick foles remember
that was way back in week three
trailing to the falcons nick foles comes
in comes back and wins the game folz is
installed as the starting quarterback on
a gut-feeling type basis he held that
job until suffering a butt injury
against the vikings on a monday night
several weeks ago did nagi screw things
up by going with foals shireen
he surprised me all the way through this
thing on on how he's picked these
quarterbacks and i think we all thought
going into the season it was going to be
nick foles and that was the surprise
when he picked mitchell trubisky to
start the season as a quarterback and
they were 3-0 and i realized foals came
in and saved the day in the third of
those games and the teams they played
were not very good the lions the giants
and the falcons i i get that but they
were three and oh and foles as we've
said all along he's a great backup
quarterback he's never started more than
11 games in a season that was 2015 with
the rams there's a reason why he's a
great backup perhaps the greatest backup
in nfl history i would have kept him in
that backup role see what i have and
mitchell trubisky but you're trying to
get to the playoffs you're trying to
keep your job there's all these other
things that come into it but now they've
got to figure out what they have in
mitchell trubisky and what they're going
to do at the quarterback position after
the season i just think they have huge
questions now mike at that position
trubisky do to become a free agent
because they didn't pick up the fifth
year option unless they run the table
and make it to the playoffs and win a
game or two they won't use the franchise
tag or the transition tag on mr trubisky
you're talking about too big of a
financial commitment so he'll hit the
open market and the incentive for him
quite simply is to play as well as he
can to get someone else interested in
giving trubisky a chance for 2021. much
like carson wentz he may just need a
change of scenery but i'm not ready to
say neggy ruined the season he did what
he thought was right under the
circumstances i don't know that they
would have been much better with
trubisky playing i think this was a
total failure of the offense in recent
weeks they've tried to do some different
things it's too late for that but i feel
like they were destined to lose all
those games even if they had stuck with
trubisky new york nick asks this
question does home field advantage in
the playoffs matter in 2020 shireen
well
what is the difference between playing
in new orleans in a dome in green bay
outside so i would say absolutely yes
the bigger thing even than that mike
though is getting that first round bye
since there's only one of them this year
i think it's vitally important to get
the number one seed to have home field
and as rodney's going to talk about as i
alluded to earlier aaron rodgers hasn't
had that championship game at home and
can you imagine green bay even without
fans in january with aaron rodgers and
probably a snowy game that would be a
lot of fun but new orleans wants to be
in a dome of course and they want to get
that home field for just that reason
yeah i remember
a playoff game at home 2011 where the
packers had been 15-1 heavily favored
over the giants and they blew that i
just think they've got the propensity
to have a stinker at some point in the
playoffs even if they end up with the
one seed
those two games there's a chance that
after the fact much like what you said
earlier about sean payton the exact same
quotes from last year when they lost to
the falcons there's a card out there
that aaron rodgers has ready to go with
passive aggressive shots about the team
not having sufficient energy the team
not being ready to play the team not
being ready to execute without ever
saying who's the blame for that but we
all know who's to blame for the favor of
a team to prepare because sean payton
admits it's the coach when that happens
but that that's where my my doubt is and
i hope
and in a look i don't want to be
picking favorites here but man i'd love
to see aaron rodgers and patrick mahomes
in the super bowl that would be
compelling that would be exciting i
don't know that the packers could beat
the chiefs but it would be great to see
that match up but first the packers have
to get there whether they have the home
field advantage or not i think that you
can you can count on the possibility of
the packers blowing it at home but
otherwise it's not the same as the home
field advantage would be in other years
because there's no crowd there and one
thing we've seen in record numbers this
season come backs from 10 or more points
behind because if you're the road team
there's no noise to deal with as you try
to come back and if you're the home team
there's no booing to deal with as you
try to come back as your fans are all
upset that you've played so poorly so
that could be a factor in the postseason
as well one more real quickly j.r the
boss man
does the brown's performance without
otto beckham make it more likely that
he'll be traded in the off-season
shireen
well they've certainly been good without
and mike and they have proved our point
that we thought they were going to be a
better offense without him and they are
it allows them to run the ball which
they're really good at
takes the ball out of baker's hands and
he spread the ball around four
touchdowns last week to four different
receivers i think they're better without
odell beckham
yeah and if you have any doubt about
that because i've i've said all along
they'd be better off without him because
in the passing game you don't
have to focus on odell beckham jr and
maybe wait too long for him to come open
and not get through your progressions
fast enough just throw the open guy go
through your progressions throw to the
open guy if you don't have that guy
who's who's sucking up all the attention
and footballs but look for stefan diggs
quotes about why he wanted out of
minnesota when you become run centric
you alienate star receivers and otto
beckham jr would have been alienated by
the new offense in cleveland as they go
heavy with nick chubb and kareem
hunt hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports